die syncmate blume erhöhen meine lieben
freunde und herzlich willkommen hier zu
einer weiteren folge von minecraft leben
ihr gebt euch mal einfach wie cool das
aussieht rechts im bild mit diesem mit
diesem shader dass da einfach sich sogar
die regentropfen die habe ich ja
teilweise sogar einfach auf dem
bildschirm von im regen das sieht
richtig geil aus ich habe nicht vor das
minecraft leben jeden tag kommt weil ich
finde wenn es jeden tag kommt ihr zu
eintönig deswegen habe ich mir gedacht
dass es einfach so ab und zu kommt also
wird zäher jeden zweiten tag oder so mal
keine ahnung wie ich das ganze machen
werde und ich habe in der zwischenzeit
ein wenig weiter gebaut weil ich war
vier tage lang unterwegs
und deswegen habe ich natürlich ein
laptop mitgenommen und natürlich auch
ein wenig auf dem server hier gespielt
ich möchte nämlich hier mein haus also
erst mal ich zeige euch was hier gemacht
habe ich habe hier das ganze ein
bisschen gerade gemacht und dann wenn
nicht hier hinten hingehen moment wenn
ich jetzt warum geht da wo ich wünsche
ihm her gelaufen denn hier oben habe ich
das ganze so gemacht weil hier oben
kommt ein haus von mir drauf also soll
übergang quasi und hier unten habe ich
auch ein haus und das hier erinnert euch
wahrscheinlich schon so ein bisschen
eigentlich hatte ich hier auch noch was
hingebaut dass das netzwerk in zwar
konnte ihr sohn hoppelt haus hin
das hatte ich dann habe ich das dann
gesagt ich meine ich sogar glaube ich
noch gar nicht gesagt ich hatte diesmal
der sturm war für meine ich in der folge
sagt oder hab ich überhaupt schon mal
gesagt jedenfalls wollte ich das ganze
so machen wie das carol s hat darüber
glaube ich ein video mal gemacht wie man
ein hobbit haus baut so in etwa wollte
das aufbauen habe ich mir zum beispiel
daran genommen
deswegen habe ich jetzt auch die
ziegelsteine genommen ob ich das ganze
nicht noch nachher durch andere steine
ersetzt muss ich dann schauen was sich
daraus ergibt aber ich habe auf jeden
fall so ein bisschen hier angebaut wie
ich das mache mit denen das ist falsch
ich das mache mit den treppen wie ich
das mache mit den fans dann und so
weiter also einfach so ein bisschen mir
daran mich daran orientiere wie er das
ganze gebäude ist schon wieder falsch
die intuition nehme und zwar wollte den
eingang zu machen wer den gemacht hat
und dann wenn ich dann rein geht es dann
hier quasi mein haus und wenn ich dann
machen
coole wendeltreppe nach oben irgendwie
natürlich ganze mittelalter stil und
dann ist hier oben quasi mein weiteres
haus und dann werde ich hier noch so ein
wasserfall runter laufen lassen überall
an den rändern warte ich zeige euch das
mal wie ich das hier machen wollte hier
habe ich extra schon ein bisschen runter
gegraben weil da kommt zum wasserfall
runter sind einen kleinen bach ein
das wird hoffentlich ganz cool in den
natürlichen welche ideen habt wie ich
das ganz bauen könnte oder so könnt ihr
das auch in die kommentare schreiben
und ich wollte jetzt eigentlich hier
sonntag ich habe so ein plakat ein paar
kleinigkeiten macht übrigens sorry das
ich mega fertig aussehen aber ich habe
ein bisschen geschlafen weil wir gleich
super bowl schaut werden
und deswegen brauchen wir einfach kräfte
hin geschrieben ich habe ein bisschen
gerade geschlafen weil wir gleich super
bowl schauen werden das heißt ich hab
dich in rote augen und du aber ich habe
quasi einfach nur wollte euch schnell
zeigen was ich alles so off screen
gebaut habe also einfach das hier
aufgeschüttet und so und eine richtige
mauer zu saft zu saphir jahr über gebaut
zusa fällt irgendwie falsch und jetzt
werde ich auch mal eben schauen weil ich
jetzt auch schon zwei tage lang nicht
mehr in der in der farm welt war was
sich da dann so verändert hat und ich
wollte euch eine kleine rund führung
geben aber ich weiß nicht ob ich das in
dieser folge überhaupt noch schaffe so
lange wie ich euch jetzt alles gezeigt
haben brauchen nämlich endlich mal eine
vernünftige rüstung das einzige was ich
habe sind lederstiefel die haben zwar
die haben echt ganz gute verzauberungen
aber ich bräuchte denke ich echt mal
reisen um eine vernünftige rüstung
machen zu können ich werde auch
demnächst in zukunft streamen sobald das
mit switch geregelt ist dass das kann
weil ich möchte echt
die partner werden weil natürlich auch
man kann mit twitter geld verdienen dass
das weiß glaube ich jeder allerdings
geht es mir halt auch darum dass sich
der mainstream viele darüber beschwert
wenn man meint höhe die qualität ist
viel zu gut geschafft mein rechner gar
nicht ich kann ihn nicht unterstellen
und das sieht einfach so schön aus mit
der sonne die dann so um den berg roma
wundervolles haben sich einfach viele
leute beschwert und die meinten halte ja
wir können die qualität nicht
unterstellen du musst rich partner sein
und was alles und deswegen habe ich das
jetzt mein angriff genommen werden das
jetzt hoffentlich hinkriegen irgendwie
beim ein netzwerk das sich da brauche
ich dachte schon ich weil er seine
riesige schlucht und das jetzt
hoffentlich hinkriegen dass ich
irgendwann in den nächsten tagen einen
partner binden
11freunde sieht das geil oder geil aus
mit dem shader ich weiß nicht ob ich der
einzige bin der darüber immer so aber
ich weiß noch nicht
guck mal das mit dem nebel deswegen
freunde deswegen habe ich die sichtweite
auf so gering weil es einfach so geil
aussieht mit das als wenn also nebel als
wenn das so gerade morgentau ist und so
und das etwas unscharfe ich finde dass
es so somit das schönste in minecraft
dass wenn man diesen das ist einfach
direkt ob man einfach diesen diesem
shader benutzen kann das ist richtig
schön und mit dem wasser und so ist
einfach perfekt ich könnte jetzt noch
viel länger darüber schwärmen ach so ich
habe übrigens auch noch seinen weg
gebaut den kann ich euch auch noch mal
zeigen und ich wollte euch eigentlich
eine stadtführung geben
aber jetzt habe ich euch auf jeden fall
erstmal mein haus gezeigt zuckerrohr
durch das zuckerrohr mit und sand
endlich ich hab so lange sand gesuchte
der normalen welt weil ich unbedingt ihr
ding machen wollte mich wollt unbedingt
fenster machen und jetzt geht's einfach
endlich das ist echt schlimm in der
normalen welt findet man nahezu nichts
mehr deswegen gibt es auch immer diese
farbenwelt ihn also ab und zu wechseln
und das ist echt richtig schön bei der
normalen welt habe ich bin ich einfach
so lange herum gelaufen und habe seinen
gesucht und eisen und einfach nichts
gefunden ich habe ein bisschen kohle
gefunden und ein zwei eisen blöcke und
paar gold blog aber die konnte ich
abhauen weil ich ja kein eisen
spitzhacke alaba zum glück gibt es diese
farm welt meine lieben freunde also
zurück zu den streams die werden dann
kommen wir nicht fritsch partner bin
also wenn wirklich jeder sich die
qualität einstellen kann weil die stream
in seiner qualität dass die nicht für
jeden mit einer normalen leitung quasi
zugänglich ist ich hoffe ich hab das
jetzt irgendwie richtig gesagt wenn
nicht dann sind wahrscheinlich genutzt
wird zu schied schon genügend which
zuschauer in der in den platz aber ich
sind genügend which zuschauer in den
kommentaren hier vorhanden die denke ich
wissen was ich damit zum ausdruck
bringen möchte so und jetzt werde ich
mal schauen dass sie nicht so schön
ok einzige was ich noch brauche ist clay
und ein bisschen eisen
aber was ich auch noch mal sagen wollten
zwar diese nächsten folgen werden dann
natürlich nicht so sein dass ich einfach
rum lauf von farben und ein bisschen der
zelle bei gott in die welt und was ich
so mache sondern in zukunft werde ich
dann auf twitter einfach fragen oder dem
hashtag lukas leben oder so also unter
diesem hashtag bei bei twitter oder
irgendwas anders keine ahnung werde ich
mir noch aussuchen da werde ich euch
dann einfach fragen ob ihr irgendwelche
fragen habt anm ich das hörte sich jetzt
doppelt gemoppelt an aber ich glaube es
war richtig guckt euch mal das
mit dem mit dem mit dem ich möchte nicht
lange genug über diesen diesen diesen
shader hier schwärmen also da werde ich
dann euch fragen ob ihr fragen habt dann
mich die ich dann natürlich beantworten
werde
in den folgen und in den streams wird
auch einfach darum gehen dass ich das
quasi live mache also diese videos von
von minecraft leben werden einfach
irgendwo also diese videos von minecraft
leben werden quasi so sein dass ich
immer so wie jetzt gerade einfach hier
ein bisschen lager und das ganze auch
schneider also wirklich wird kratzt drin
und euch nur sachen zeigen wie wenn ich
jetzt beispielsweise clay finde oder
irgendwas anderes guckt euch mal an
diese blöcke sind sogar so wellenförmig
wie das wasser und in den streams wird
das ganze dann quasi einfach anders sein
also dass ich euch wo ich dachte nicht
kriegt einfach keine luft mehr in den
stream wird das ganze dann am kap sein
das heißt ich werde den streams
ebenfalls farmen bauen und fragen
beantworten
allerdings im stream dann irgendwie 2 34
stunden kommt auch an wie viel zeit ich
habe und es einfach dass er dabei live
zuschauen können und live fragen stellen
können und hier ist es dann einfach so
dass ich das ganze einfach ein bisschen
bearbeitet damit es nicht zu langweilig
wird für euch und schaut euch das an
ich weiß nicht dass ich möchte die ganze
zeit screenshots davon machen weil es
einfach so mega schön aus sieben diesem
shader viele hatten mich gefragt wie er
heißt der highschool shader und den
hatte ich zum beispiel noch bei noch gar
keinen im projekt gesehen und
wahrscheinlich werden jetzt viele
benutzen aber dass auch schön weil ich
finde dieser sei saddam dem markt gar
nicht weil wenn ich ohne spaß jetzt
einfach mal ganz kurz viele im projekt
hier benutzte auch den song shelter
natürlich es gibt verschiedene
geschmäcker
aber ich finde also man muss das
natürlich selbst entscheiden aber dieser
hier ist halt so der achte lauf kleine
sachen zb ich habe keine kleine
regentröpfchen auf dem bildschirm und
ich sehe hier dass sich das hier so
spiegelt in dem gras ich sehe ganz
hinten das einfach mit nebel das wasser
ist perfekt und dann wenn ich jetzt
einfach mal zudem soll es schneller
wechsel finde ich das ganze irgendwie
überhaupt nicht so schön das sieht alles
düster aus und um diese blöcke sind gar
nicht so und also ich muss sagen der
shader auf entfernung mit dieser und mit
dieser unschärfe weg dieser seiner
entfernung mit dieser unschärfe und so
ist mega nice dass das fällt mir aber
gerade auch erst auf wo ich hier diese
weit entfernten inseln sehe aber so
doch mit der unschärfe schon ganz geil
mit dem wasser geht eigentlich auch
schon fit aber so finde ich einfach den
coupon shader als als kompletten shader
einfach besser den kudamm shader den
finde ich so einfach viel schöner aber
der der soll schneller das ist klar da
geht eine ferne viel geiler an einer
ohne witz irgendwie einen kader
zusammenstellen mit der unschärfe vom
sei es am ende und alles andere von
american express und ja keine ahnung
bisher bestand die folge quasi daraus
dass ich euch gesagt habe wie mein haus
werden soll dass ich mit euch warm war
und dass ich gesagt habe was sie
zwischen einem stream und einem video
ist ich hab ne gute idee was wir jetzt
machen und zwar lockt ich mich einfach
mal eben ganz kurz aus so dass ich
wieder in den normalen welt drinnen bin
und das mache ich eben ja und da bin ich
wieder meine lieben freunde hier sind
wir wieder in minecraft leben weil das
ist ein toller zusatzeffekt ich kann
einfach guckt dass das finde ich einfach
so schön an diesem kula shaker das ist
einfach so da nimmt die fackel in die
hand und dann leuchtet es um mich rum
und du dich schon spitzen spitzen china
kräftig schwitzen ich finde bei uns ins
haus und muss es auch noch so ein
bisschen werden die hier so ein bisschen
wohnlicher ich bin wenn ich hier lang
laufe sehr gut hier wieder nicht hier
ist ein bisschen einfach wirklich nur so
ein weg aber so ist es halt grad genau
bei uns erstellt der bildkarten arsch
komme hallo geschenk mein blume danke
okay ich soll das ist wieder so
das sieht einfach so mega schön aus mit
diesem mond und alle möglichen das finde
ich einfach am aller coolsten aber was
eigentlich der sinn von dieser folge
sein sollte war eigentlich so ein
bisschen ein haus zu zeigen und mit euch
sondern kleine stadtführung zu machen
was ich geschafft habe ist ich war mit
euch farben
ich habe eine blume geschenkt bekommen
ich habe eine menge um den heißen brei
geredet und das war es auch eigentlich
schon als typischer auf meinem
grundstück nach hause
gucken tracken kordon ich geh jetzt mal
hier ebenso ein paar sachen rein ich
brauche auch einfach noch mal kohle oder
so was ich packe jetzt das hier erst mal
hier rein einfach vorbei du im moment
die behinderte volkswagen
so und jetzt zeige ich euch noch ganz
eben was ich also das ist wirklich quasi
das einzige was ich geschafft habe beim
beim als sich so eingespielt habe obwohl
das eigentlich schon eine ganz schöne
menge ist obwohl man das nicht denkt
aber ihr wisst ihr glaube ich wie vorher
das grundstück aus doch vorher war das
wirklich einfach nur sein kumpel kasten
und das habe ich jetzt zumindest schon
mal so ein bisschen geordnet und was ich
halt auch noch gemacht habe ist ich hab
mir eine bessere weg anbindung gemacht
also wie ich finde besser ein paar
meinen auch so direkt zu hell was ist
das denn nicht meine sache hier lebt
noch dass es kunst und zwar habe ich das
einfach hier gemacht dass caesar
hochgeht moment ist jetzt hier mal eben
noch fackeln damit das ganze auch ein
bisschen erhält ist also hier geht es
dann so lange erstmals den weg hier so
lange macht das der hier so in der ecke
mündet und dass er hier halt gerade
verläuft
und hier gerade verlassen wollen diese
ganzen zombies ihr angeht er hier halt
hoch und das hier fand ich eigentlich
war so eine idee von mir und zwar dass
ich hier so eine kleine wasserquelle hin
mache also einfach das hier so ein
bisschen wasser ist es schon recht bitte
mit shader mit den punkten und dem ziel
dann wieder raus geht ist sie lang war
sie der weg wieder so ganz normal weiter
da könnte ich hier noch mal eben eine
fackel dran platzieren damit ein
bisschen heller ist ich könnte auch noch
mal eben das mache ich einfach wenn ich
wenn ich auf streamen oder so sind so
kleinigkeiten
also einfach dass der weg war sie von
hier sieht aus als wenn das ein ganz
normaler berg wer aber da geht dann
quasi der weg hier einfach durch und das
ein kleiner wasserteilchen geht's hier
wieder langweilig einfach ein bisschen
schöner bauen um ein grundstück herum
und was sich demnächst einmal noch
machen werde ist dass ich versuche hier
so einfluss lang laufen zu lassen also
von hier oben von meinem haus
ich sollte ich echt mal ausleuchten
damit ihr nicht so ganz viele böse
zombies drops bauen also was ich
versuchen möchte ist auf jeden fall dass
ich erstmal diesen zombie hier töte und
das sich dann quasi wenn hier oben ein
haus steht hier einfluss runter laufen
lassen und der soll dann irgendwie hier
drunter unterirdisch ergehen und dann
noch hier das grundstück von der person
hier vorne geht ja nur bis hier das
heißt ich werde das oder das zumindest
dieser zeit wird den fluss hier
irgendwie lang laufen lassen
keine ahnung ich das ganze machen werde
das war es auf jeden fall erstmal für
diese zweite voll gemeinschaft leben
ich hoffe die folge gefallen wenn es das
getan hat würde ich mich über eine
bewertung freuen wir sehen uns in live
streams wieder oder auf twitter oder
instagram auf facebook oder auf
sonstigen der plattform ich schaut super
bowl wir sehen uns
ja